here is the Smoking Gun
he didn't even wasn't behind closed
doors it was open that Trump invited and
demanded that Russia Clute and uh Eli in
your uh wonderful uh most recent episode
of the re-education you talk about how
uh a great journalist like Jonathan
Roush points to this or or says Trump on
occasions openly invited the Russians to
meddle in the election this is the clip
that we're talking about let's let's run
this thing what do I have to get
involved with Putin if I have nothing to
do with Putin I've never spoken to him I
don't know anything about him other than
he will respect me
doesn't respect our president
and if it is Russia which is probably
not nobody knows who it is but if it is
Russia
it's really bad for a different reason
because it shows how little respect they
have for our country when they would
hack into a major party
and get everything
but it would be interesting to see I I
will tell you this Russia if you're
listening I hope you're able to find the
30 000 emails that are missing
I think you will probably be rewarded
mightily by our press
was that collusion
the dead to rights
get them in an orange jumpsuit Rock
March them out
that's it you know where's the justice
department
yeah we've cracked the code
really really have you never seen this
guy before I mean it's just like he's a
nightclub comedian who happened to be
like prep I mean he's this is all like
his patter in some ways and it seems to
me I mean maybe I'm wrong but I
interpreted that as saying I don't have
anything to do with the Russians by the
way that was wrong when he said that
um his fixer Mike Cohen was trying to uh
arrange a deal that never happened to
build a Trump Tower in Moscow okay and
then he says uh you know it would be
really bad uh if it was the Russians
because it shows how little respect
which is true it does show how little
respect they have to the United States
and then uh you know he's then talking
about
the missing emails that were the was the
the kind of prevailing narrative at the
time which was well what up she deleted
all these emails and they didn't charged
attack or anybody else and like it's not
unfair and you know what was in those
emails that was so you know there must
have been something so devastating that
they got rid of them which also is not
sure it's not clear right well it's yeah
it's it's like that if you want to that
it's kind of that that's a that's a
little bit of an innuendo kind of attack
too on the other hand
um again I look at it as a matter of
sort of double standards if somebody in
the Trump campaign even if it was a
junior junior chipmunk like a George
Papadopoulos had deleted information
that was subpoenaed by Congress do you
really think everybody would be like oh
who cares what then that's not a big
deal I didn't do it for corrupt reasons
so
um but anyway that's what he was that's
what he was getting at he was like well
you know you can find them and I can and
we now know because of the Mueller
report that there really was Trump was
obsessed with finding those emails so he
contracted people to you know he asked
Mike Flynn to go find them and and I
think there were people who were willing
to go try to get them from anyone but
that is not and it doesn't have anything
to do with what the Russians actually
did they hacked the DNC and they hacked
John podesta and they gave us it was
separate emails they're both emails but
it's different things and
um again I don't I I don't think I'll
ever convince David from or Jonathan
Roush or
law fair or you know Ben with us I'm
probably never going to convince them
that this is like what is this like how
how is that count of any of anything but
they I mean it was certainly saying we
also know I mean listen when this
started and people thought that Trump
was going to get nailed by Mueller so
for the nobody said in those first two
and a half years of the Trump years like
hey they already got him look what he
said in July 27th you know 2016 right
right it's right there on tape why do we
have to do any more investigating that's
collusion everybody no they thought they
were going to find but you know was
described in the steel dossier
well-developed conspiracy and like Paul
manafort and Michael Cohen and Prague
and all this other stuff none of it true
the way that Trump himself has reacted
to the Durham report is worth talking
about a little bit I think because he
has a certain manner that he likes to
frame things we all remember you know
hoax uh Witch Hunt crime of the century
or the the terms that he generally
throws out there and he was recently on
Dan bongino's show reacting to the uh
Durham report so let's just play that
clip and I'm curious to hear your
thoughts Eli as to what Trump had to say
this was a coup and if I didn't fire yes
tell me probably you wouldn't have made
it I wouldn't have made it at this great
Administration that did so much wouldn't
have made it because Comey this was a
whole coup they were ready to go in if I
didn't fire Comey he would have walked
in with struck and Paige and this one
and McCabe
and there was a sir I'm sorry but the
Russia thing I said what Russia thing
can you imagine if you would have been
taken out of office for something that
you never even heard about these are bad
people these are sick people
was this uh an attempted coup
uh you know that's over the top
I don't like I mean I it's not a coup in
the sense if there wasn't like a general
who
you know got a group of officers to
storm the White House but it was
certainly
uh an outrageous kind of interference
as I said in the in the in the
transition uh in the presidential
transition uh the FBI leadership's
actions I mean remember in March of 2017
again the FBI has zero evidence at this
point Comey tells the house intelligence
committee there's an ongoing
investigation and tremendous campaign
having to do with Russia confirming by
the way stories that were already leaked
to the New York Times in the Washington
Post and everybody else
why would he do that
he mentions the investigation in 2016
initially in July in order to say he's
not charging Clinton also highly unusual
but why would he then bring up this in
an open-ended investigation when again
the FBI had nothing with the exception
of the Steele dossier which was
disinformation so and the FBI by the way
at that point knew that dinchenko was
walking away from it you can go through
the list of all of the problems they
offered steel a million dollars we could
corroborate and he couldn't
so all of that information is somewhere
the CIA looked at it and said they
thought it was junk and shouldn't be
included in the intelligence assessment
so it's Comey out there who then says I
need to confirm this and everything like
that and by the way it was such a moment
such a Watergate like you know West Wing
drama moment the FBI director is
announcing an ongoing investigation into
the sitting president holy Tahiti and it
confirmed so many of the priors of
people who still bitter about the the
you know Trump winning that election
that we've sort of stopped and and and
we didn't really capture like or examine
like what what the hell is the FBI
director doing yeah why would he make
that announcement and now we know there
was no reason for him to make that
announcement we now know that that what
he said was I mean why would you say
that that it should have pretty much
been closed at that point so
um I wouldn't call it a coup but I don't
have much sympathy and even though at
the time you know Trump couldn't have
screwed up more about how he ended up
how he fired Comey and bragging to you
know the Russian Ambassador the Russian
foreign minister in the white house the
next day about how he was crazy and
everything like that all really that was
bad but probably one of the best things
that Trump didn't it was getting rid of
Jim Comey that was an excerpt from
reasons live stream with Eli Lake
dissecting the Durham report if you want
to watch the whole conversation go here
if you want to watch another excerpt go
here and tune in next Thursday at 1 pm
eastern time because Zach wise Miller
and I here will be back here with a
great guest thanks for watching